bb rexa bravo bravo bravo and
congratulations to you let me just say
this to you miss bibi
or at one of your songs say my name is
stevie but you can call me bv i like
that
listen you made us wait three years for
this album but i have to tell you it's
certainly worth the wait
and it seems to me i've been listening
to your music for a while now that
you've been
trying to talk about this for a long
time you know when you look at the
lyrics of your own
your songs i'll show you crazy i'm a
little messy certainly sabotaged
you call this your most personal album
but have you been trying to discuss this
and been told
nope you shouldn't talk about this bb a
hundred percent
by the way gail he's saying that is so
awesome so thank you no it's good your
album is really good
but yeah i got you know in the past i
had a different team around me and i had
a song that i'd written
called i'm gonna show you crazy and we
had put it on spotify at the time and it
was you know
uh spotify wasn't really a thing in the
us and
it garnered all these plays and i
remember having a team member telling me
we can't put this to radio not yet it's
it's who it's too much it's too heavy
and i was like i don't think so i think
this is something we need to
talk about and of course there is a
theme but this is part of my life and
this is something that i've been dealing
with and i'm
and i would i wish growing up i would
have had my favorite
artist talk about mental health yeah i
think it's important because you got to
see it
for people to say listen this is
happening to me too what did you learn
about yourself during this time you call
it your most personal album and it
really is you really go
all the way there bb with what you're
thinking and how you're feeling
and some of it isn't so good yeah
um i i feel like for me
uh it's it's tough
if we all are going through something
and i what i've
learned is to be compassionate and to
accept
who you are for the longest time i would
go to
industry parties or i just didn't really
want to play the game
i just wanted to write songs and be part
of music and in the entertainment
industry
you kind of have to play that game be
seen you know they tell you to be seen
and date other celebrities and i'm just
not about that
life and i would always judge myself
because i would get so
anxious being you know just being a part
of any of that
and there's nothing wrong with it it's
just that i learned you know what this
is who i am
i just want to write songs i just want
to help other people
and make other make fans not feel alone
that's my main thing is is to normalize
not always being perfect
i think with media sorry it's
anthony i'm sorry i didn't interrupt you
um but when you when you're writing
these songs that are so personal
is it scary to put this down
yeah especially i think with my mother
for the first moment like when i was
talking about all this stuff
she had me super young she was 18 and i
and
she always kind of feels like maybe she
did something wrong and i try to explain
that to her like
mom you know you did the best you could
this is just something i want to speak
about
it this has nothing to do with with you
like you did a great job and it gets
scary sometimes because i don't want to
be labeled
uh for me this is this
is about breaking the mold and the
stigma and helping people
it's not just about writing songs you
know
making money is great and having success
and the reputation is it's great
but what is my purpose and i want to
help
people well you're going to help people
with this with this album certainly the
lyrics are knockout i love uh the song
that's amore i love your take on it
because it goes when the moon hits your
eye like a beat like a big pizza pie
that's amore we know that part but bibi
says
when you wake in a dream wrapped in
versace sheets that's amore
and i love the line about a guy taking
you to positano my type of guy
just because you asked to go i like it i
like it
that's my amore is my dad's favorite
song i grew up in new york
and we were albanian and he would always
listen to that song gail
when the moon hit the eye like a big he
would always sing it and i'd be like
i always get in my head so i was like i
gotta remake this song in some way
i love your take on it with rick ross
you seem to be in a good place bb rex i
know it's an ongoing thing are you in a
good place
i am yeah thank god i am uh i've been
just you know especially during this
quarantine just been trying to work on
myself
and one thing i learned is compassion
yeah uh
just being compassionate with yourself
because one thing that i've noticed is
we are always so nice to other people
we're constantly getting compliments
but when we feel i never i've learned to
give myself compliments and that's why
i'm very
excited just with my mental health i'm
really excited to be partnering with
pinterest for this because
compassion i say compassion and kindness
and i love that
the title i know we got to go i'm going
john i love the title better mistakes
because we could all do that make better
mistakes thank you bieber rex uh thank
you
thank you guys thank you really good to
see you